this is a song I wrote about a certain
situation I was in
[Music]
diarrhea makes it hard oh now watch it
squirt it's almost like a part but then
your anus has to pur diarrhea is a ninja
never know when it goes down like when
you're on a date and then your stomach's
like a plow then she's like why are you
sweating some range then you're like
baby don't worry about oh then you let a
tiny fart to relieve the pressure in
your cut check your drawers check your
drawers run into the bathroom stall cuz
you ain't gonna get no coochie Shino you
[ __ ] your balls oh my god oh my god I
think my rectum just got torn what the
hell I don't remember when's the last
time I ate cool anyways we went back to
her crib got all comfortable and [ __ ]
just in case' coma hold I tightened up
real tight like this suddenly things got
all sweaty and we got all hot and heavy
as she grabbed my ass oh god the bit
released the do too lady
I pushed a bit down the way so don't
stop love me okay she was lying was
wrong why'd you push me off don't tell
me why I cover your ears if you don't
you my kids
she's lying why's it sound like you're
squeezing ketchup bottles up in
taia RIA is no joke
it affects millions every day just
listen to this song and please just
learn from my mistakes so just remember
if you caught it and you're on a real
hard date
tell her it must unyk hurts we gotta be
scheduled this is my doo doo butter PSA
he wants someone I love up not just any
other you regularly she alien got paper
she boho but she's talking all the time
anywhere I see though she'll you stare
in horror see bees and you like give it
here
but she can't let you have it listen
there are a few things in this world
that sound ungodly rhinoceros is having
sex
giraffes being slaughtered gorillas
getting punched in the dick and now we
have this
[Music]
it literally sounds like two Tigers